all of this is being done in the open
and on platforms like gofundme
um on cash app on demo and probably the
most successful campaign
in portland like minnesota was there was
a bell fund that was set up
so that immediately the few people who
actually had bails
set because their charges were so
serious
they would immediately get bailed out
immediately and then the charges would
be dropped anyways
so they would get the money back and
they would reinvest that another thing
such as giving grants
to other antique chapters
you know i know that just because i know
you personally i know
that some of the the sort of fame or
notoriety that this has come with
is not what you were looking for and
when i saw you that day you know a
couple weeks after you were attacked you
were obviously having
some uh some mental difficulties some
cognitive stuff that i'm thrilled to see
or you're better obviously
but you've sort of become part of the
story which is a weird thing for a
journalist and
portland they they post about you you
know i mean quite literally things like
kill
andy no i mean there are there are awful
things the mobs that come after you
online like i get a lot of hate but your
your hate might trump my hate uh andy
i i think it's possible can you talk
about that about just how
personally that's been for you and how
it sort of
sucked you in to the to the machine here
yeah so it's you know antifascist
extremism is not just their violence on
the streets they
a huge part of their intimidation
is done through online for things that
are
borderline uh not illegal
such as showing up at people's homes
making it known that they know where you
live for example
writing um your address
in public places and writing kill and
murder
andy no um they wanted me to live
under like a constant fear
and um it's unfortunate that they
did succeed in that and because
at times when i was just carrying out
regular activities in life
like going to the gym or grocery
shopping one of their
members or sympathizers would recognize
me and
post uh and use some of these hashtags
that would then be reshared really
quickly with
the intended goal to sort of do a cyber
swarm
where through online information they
show up in real life to harass people
that's actually how they were able to
assault
ted wheeler one of them happened to see
him at a restaurant
so it's throughout 2020
i've been i was really on borrowed time
in portland
they had fully doxxed me uh
threatened to kill me many times all
this is reported to
police uh and nothing ever happened
and so um did you ever try to escalate
it beyond
local portland police like did you ever
talk to the fbi or anything like that
i did report a lot of it to the fbi and
i never even heard back
they took an initial report and nobody
followed up with me
not even once god it's just incredible
so
um let's talk a little bit more about
the the online component of this
because i know finally in the last
couple weeks it looks like twitter did
remove a couple big antifa accounts
um we can all debate the merits of free
speech and whether they were
coordinating violence and all that sort
of thing
but where else are they coordinating
because i know when they
if i tweet something that's sort of
against antifa and then i suddenly get
literally
thousands of responses often telling me
to go kill myself or they're gonna come
get me or whatever
whatever it might be um that there's
obviously some level of coordination
there's there are things happening not
just on twitter
do you know about those sort of networks
yeah it's all right about that in the
book
um a lot of the organizing actually
is done right and open through twitter
and
being banned it's not really um
much of a handicap to them because these
accounts are all
anonymous anyways and they're plugged
until
they're connected to one another beyond
twitter through things such as signal
and telegram
so when a major account is banned and
they open up just another one
immediately
that is announced through these channels
so then they immediately get new
followers
um but in portland in particular twitter
was the platform where most of the riot
organizing happened so you had like
all these ad hoc antifa groups that
popped up in the summer
2020 that provided um crap
fundraise for riot gear um
food food was the big thing and not
insignificant because that helped
attract
uh vagrants who formed a big part of
their part of their units for rioting um
money for travel they went to other
cities there was some of them who went
to
kenosha some of them who went to dc and
all this was being done
in the open and on platforms like
gofundme um
on cash app on demo and probably the
most successful campaign
in portland like minnesota was there was
a bell fund that was set up
so that immediately um of the few people
who actually had bails
set because their charges were so
serious
they would immediately get bailed out
immediately and then the charges would
be dropped anyways
so they would get the money back and
they would reinvest on another thing
such as giving grants
to other chapters so this is what i mean
this issue of allowing it to go on so
long is that these systems and networks
will last
long beyond um summer of 2020
and um a lot of that unfortunately is
also out of the reach
of law enforcement such as the encrypted
communications that happen on signal or
telegram
right and we know that a whole bunch of
hollywood celebrities were promoting
those gofundmes to get these guys out
and am i
am i mistaken but didn't kamala harris
actually promote one
at one time she did she did i write
about that in the book
so um she tweeted out a link
to her millions of followers for the
minnesota freedom fund which was
the group that paid the bail for accused
riders in minnesota
but it wasn't just rioters that were
being bailed out this organization was
also paying the bill for
accused murderers accused rapists
i mean just just staggering stuff what
about the relationship though with big
tech because obviously after the capitol
hill riots on the sixth
we know what happened with parlor their
servers were taken out by amazon
we know trump was banned by basically
everybody
as i said before a couple antifa
accounts have been taken out
but they really do play footsie with
these things and as you just said
twitter is probably the main culprit
here
yes so um they've taken down a few
uh antique accounts but these are just
drops in the bucket
and then rose city antifa is still on
the youth liberation front
is still on twitter and these are groups
that were instrumental
in years of violence in portland
um but the thing with big tech is um i
mean their bias is no secret i think
it it's just it's the same thing with
journalism like
the r the staff the people who are
making up the workforce of these
large corporations they're largely
influential to excuse me sympathetic
to the cause of what they believe these
extremists are doing
right which then causes them to allow a
lot of this stuff to just slide while
on the other side they they certainly
wouldn't be as accommodating
um what do you think is sort of coming
with all of this because you know there
were a lot of people as 2020
ended there was a real feeling at least
in the mainstream media like oh
all right we got rid of trump you know
now
blm can calm down auntie calm
down things will get better
clearly after the sixth and now
everything that we've seen in our 20
some odd days
of of january 2021 like it doesn't seem
like things are going to calm down
what do you think well it didn't calm
down in
starting in november november in
portland in response to
biden winning the people who took to the
streets weren't trump supporters in
portland they were antifa
and they marched around they just
severely damaged the church and their
right their the national guard was
finally activated for the first time
that night
um too little too late in my view um
i think what's going forward is that
everything
is like the the past has already
been paid the mainstreaming of the
enough tenants of their ideology
the allies that they've gained in
important institutions
have been made and of course then the
the refined and perfected blueprints
for insurrection has also had it had
months and months
of opportunity to improve so
and establish itself so um
this whole i mean the whole pretext that
gave
antifa their meteoric uh
rise in 2016 was uh
in response to uh trump which they said
was the rise of
american fascism i mean that was
that was rubbish at that time it was a
lie
unfortunately they were um that argument
was given legitimacy through the
mainstream press
um but with trump out of the way
it's immaterial anyways because yeah
their opposition really is not too trump
as
to what to the united states and what
its founding ideals are
so these agitations to attack the us
will continue
and they've latched on currently to
attracting law enforcement because
that's going to be around regardless of
what administration would be in power
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell